(sirens ring)
- When you roll up to that line,
you are getting butterflies
in your stomach,
you're nervous, you're sweating
but once you get the bug, you get hooked
and then it's all over.
(upbeat music)
We're celebrating our 23rd year
of the Top the Cop Program
here at Sonoma Raceway.
Top the Cops is a program
where high school students
can come out to the race track
on a Wednesday night,
race their car against
a uniformed policeman
in a stock police car.
I'm Kevin McKinnie, the program director
for the Top the Cops Program.
I'm a retired law enforcement officer
from the Santa Rosa Police Department.
We've been doing this
from April through August
for the past 23 seasons.
(car engine roars)
There was illegal street
racing being done in
and around the city of Santa Rosa,
and I thought we need to
get these people over here
to the race track so they stop doing it
out on the street.
If you wanna race, fine, come on out here
and race, don't do it out on the street.
(car engine roars)
These are our future, these kids here.
- When I pull up next to
a cop at the start line
I always just think, “Oh, it'd
be great if I beat them.”
It's great feeling when you
pass them on the drag shift
going 100 miles an hour.
- There is a very competitive spirit to it,
but you know, it's all about the kids.
There's a lot of negativity
in the world today
and a lot of negativity
towards law enforcement.
What we try to do out here
is make something good, something positive
out of this program,
something that is worthwhile.
Nowhere in the country is this being done
on a regular basis.
The Top the Cops Program did help curb
illegal street racing.
It's been a great positive
program all these years.
(sirens ring)